[Music]
when you and i see something like ohio
state president announces debt-free
degree initiative it gets our attention
yeah it's it's incredible i was reading
through this and what they're doing is
they're going to offer undergraduate
students the chance to graduate
debt-free after four years with this new
initiative and that's going to include a
combination of scholarships grants and
paid internships and i love the
president christina johnson her heart
behind this
is not to
do free tuition and free college but
instead to offer this uh in exchange for
financial literacy uh financial literacy
instruction and students committing to
graduate within four years they're doing
a lot of endowment and fundraising of
course to help offset the cost of this
and what's really neat is it covers
everything tuition room board fees books
the whole shebang
so that's a pretty incredible initiative
yeah this is brilliant because it's the
way people ought to be going to college
on their own
but the president of ohio state has uh
christina johnson has just done a great
job spearheading this and all she's
saying is
we're going to help you get the
scholarships we're going to put you into
an intern program where you work
particularly in the summer between
duh
uh you know and then you go back with
that money
and we're gonna get some private funding
some private donors to be able to help
cover the difference
she said it begins with a small pilot
next year and will cover tuition room
board estimated cost of about a hundred
million a year once it's fully
implemented at the end of 10 years and
the university plans to an 800 million
dollar fundraising campaign to create an
endowment to where it just feeds that in
perpetuation
and uh it's brilliant it's a way to do
it and um
there's no reason if you're going to an
in-state school that you should have
student loans you should be able to get
enough scholarships to work enough and
manage your time and get out in four
years
not six years i love that commitment as
part of this initiative you know you
don't you're not getting free college
and it's not and it's not a uh
it's not a socialized thing she was very
clear to say that in the press release
it is not free tuition it is not free
college it's not any of that it's a
program that allows you to go to school
work get scholarships get done in four
years and be done debt-free i love this
way to go we salute you yeah they're
rolling it out next fall with 125 low
and middle income students
and uh you got to fill out financial
forms every year kind of similar to a
fafsa situation but i think it's so
great that students can do this knowing
they're going to leave with zero debt as
long as they commit to four years paid
internship really simple things that
anyone can do well and this is again
it's they're committing to doing stuff
they should be doing
so it's not like it's harsh
it's not some kind of bizarre
thing they're not training on their
souls you don't have to train tigers i
mean that's not what it is you're not
you don't have to run backwards for you
know in front of a speeding car you
don't have to do anything you work yep
you apply for scholarships
you do internship and you finish in four
years
what a concept
wow
i mean
this is neat
i hope this works i hope this is a model
that other schools can take and go we're
going to do the same thing ohio state
did and all of a sudden we're going to
see so many more students walking off
that stage completely debt-free well and
what's interesting is the associated
press which generally comes out you know
pretty much to the left of karl marx on
stuff
has given her a positive push on this
they put they took the press release
from ohio state
and ran the good parts so somehow they
convince the ap that this is a good idea
which is freaking amazing because
generally the ap is
well i think the one thing that unifies
us all regardless of your politics is
the fact that this is a mess and it's a
nightmare and i love what borrowed
future did
to to really paint the picture of where
this is at and offer a solution
yeah i agree with that
i mean regardless of politics we all
think there's a problem but the
difference is we think there's different
solutions yes and she came out on the
free market side
not the uh you should you know college
college uh
tuition is a is a human right bull crap
you know
uh so instead it's your right to go pay
for it
uh and here's how you can do it and we
have a program i love it i think it's
fabulously done it's a great initiative
it's well laid out they put enough uh
information out in the press release to
make it where the whole system is
believable
it's a 10-year
rollout it's going to take them some
time to do the thing they're doing it
right it's not announced it's not uh
flashing the pan it's not microwave
they're
but i you know i i think you could get
your
alumni behind something like this
i mean there's a
sharon ramsey scholarship at the
university of tennessee now that's cool
that's over there that the ramsey family
foundation funds every year but
i can tell you this that this is the
kind of stuff alumni that have done well
in the business world would come back
and support
kids going to school free or going to
school if they're working
and you know i would support some
scholarships for stuff like this this is
the kind of thing i think you could draw
a lot of money in so her needing to
raise 800 million dollars to
uh
create the endowment for this is very
doable yeah i think even outside people
would say i'd love to throw some money
in the pot and be generous in this way
to allow someone to go to school
debt-free that otherwise maybe couldn't
i would rather do that than be taxed
even more and be forced to so that the
government with its inefficiencies
actually decided that it was grandpa and
was going to give everybody free tuition
which is a bunch of crap yeah
i mean this is socialism
and so um this kind of stuff is a good
free market answer to generosity to get
people
through school so we salute you
the president of ohio state university
pristine president christina johnson
well done
well done some of you other universities
especially your state schools could
follow suit
it might be the smartest best things
you've ever done because higher ed kind
of has a black eye right now
uh oh by the way be sure and you watch
uh borrowed future this weekend with
your family you don't want to miss this
uh several hundred thousand have already
watched it and it's uh already stirring
up a holy ruckus which was our full
intent so be sure and watch that
documentary
and make sure some of the people in your
family that think that this student loan
thing is okay or whatever make sure they
get to see it